the other one that
back to john conway that challenges this
idea
i mean maybe to tie in the the ideas of
deformation theory and
and um and uh
limits to infinity it's this idea of
cellular automata
with uh john conway looking at the game
of life stephen wolfram's work
that i've been a big fan of for a while
celia thomas
i was wondering if you have if you have
ever encountered these kinds of objects
you ever looked at them as a
mathematician where you have very simple
rules
of tiny little objects that when taken
as a whole create
incredible complexities but are very
difficult to analyze
very difficult to make sense of even
though the one individual object
one part it's like what we were saying
about andrew wiles like you
you can look at the deformation of a
small piece to tell you about the hole
it feels like with cellular automata
or any kind of complex systems it's
it's often very difficult to say
something about the whole thing
even when you can precisely describe the
operation
of uh the small the local neighborhoods
yeah i mean i love that subject i
haven't really done research in it
myself i've played around with it i'll
send you a fun blog post i wrote where i
made some cool
texture patterns from cellular automata
um
but um and those are really always
compelling it's like
you create simple rules and they create
some beautiful textures it doesn't make
any sense actually did you see there was
a great paper i don't know if you saw
this
like a machine learning paper yes i
don't know if you want to talk about
where they were
learning the texture is like let's try
to like reverse engineer and like
learn a cellular automaton that can
reduce texture that looks like this
from the images very cool and as you say
the thing you said is i feel the same
way when i read machine learning paper
is that
what's especially interesting is the
cases where it doesn't work
like what does it do when it doesn't do
the thing that you tried to train it
yeah to do that's extremely interesting
yeah yeah that was a cool paper
so yeah so let's start with the game of
life let's start with um
or let's start with john conway so
conway
so yeah so let's start with john conway
again just i don't know
from my outsider's perspective there's
not many mathematicians
that stand out throughout the history of
the 20th century
he's one of them i feel like he's not
sufficiently recognized
i think he's pretty recognized okay well
i mean
he was a full professor of princeton for
most of his life he was sort of in
certainly at the pinnacle of
yeah but i found myself every time i
talk about conway and how excited
i am about him i have to constantly
explain to people who he is
and that's that's always a sad sign to
me but that's probably true for a lot of
mathematicians i was about to say like i
feel like you have a very elevated idea
of how famous about it
this is what happens when you grow up in
the soviet union you know you think the
mathematicians are like very very famous
yeah but i'm not actually so convinced
at a tiny tangent that
that shouldn't be so i mean there's uh
it's not obvious to me that that's one
of the like if if i were to analyze
american society that
perhaps elevating mathematical and
scientific thinking to a little bit
higher level
would benefit the society well both in
discovering the beauty of what it
is to be human and for actually creating
cool technology
better iphones but anyway john conway
yeah and conway is such a perfect
example of somebody whose humanity was
and his personality was like wound up
with his mathematics right so it's not
sometimes i think people
who are outside the field think of
mathematics as this kind of like
cold thing that you do separate from
your existence as a human being no way
your personality is in there just as it
would be in
like a novel you wrote or a painting you
painted or just like the way you walk
down the street like it's in there it's
you doing it
and conway was certainly a singular
personality um
i think anybody would say that
he was playful like everything was a
game to him
now what you might think i'm gonna say
and it's true is that he sort of
was very playful in his way of doing
mathematics
but it's also true it went both ways he
also sort of made mathematics
out of games he like looked at he was a
constant inventor of games with like
crazy names and
then he would sort of analyze those
games mathematically
um to the point that he and then later
collaborating with knuth like
you know created this number system the
surreal numbers
in which actually each number is a game
there's a wonderful book about this
called i mean there are his own books
and then there's like a book that he
wrote with burlingamp and guy called
winning ways
which is such a rich source of ideas
um and he too
kind of has its own crazy number system
in which by the way there are these
infinitesimals the ghosts of departed
quantities they're in there
now not as ghosts but as like certain
kind of two-player games
um so
you know he was a guy so i knew him when
i was a postdoc
and i knew him at princeton and our
research overlapped in some ways now it
was on stuff that he had worked on many
years before the stuff i was working on
kind of connected with stuff in group
theory which
somehow seems to keep coming up um
and so i often would like sort of ask
him a question i would sort of come upon
him in the common room and i'd ask him a
question about something
and just any time you
turned him on you know what i mean you
sort of asked a question it was just
like turning
a knob and winding him up and he would
just go and you would get
a response that was like so rich and
went so many places
and taught you so much and usually had
nothing to do with your question
yeah usually your question was just to
prompt
him you couldn't count on actually
getting the question in his brilliant
curious mindset even at that age
yeah it was uh definitely a huge loss
uh but on his game of life
which was i think he developed in the
70s as almost like a side thing
a fun little experience of life is this
um
it's a very simple algorithm it's not
really a game per se in the sense of the
kinds of games that he liked whereas
people played against each other and um
but essentially it's a game that you
play
with marking little squares on the sheet
of graph paper and in the 70s i think he
was like literally doing it with like a
pen
on graph paper you have some
configuration of squares some of the
squares in the graphic
are filled in some are not and then
there's a rule a single rule
that tells you um at the next stage
which squares are filled in and which
squares are not
sometimes an empty square gets filled in
that's called birth sometimes a
square that's filled in gets erased
that's called death and there's rules
for which squares are born and which
squares die
um it's um
the rule is very simple you can write it
on one line and then the great miracle
is that you can start from some very
innocent looking
little small set of boxes and
get these results of incredible richness
and of course nowadays you don't do it
on paper nowadays you do in a computer
there's actually a great ipad app called
golly which i really like that has like
conway's original rule and like
gosh like hundreds of other variants and
it's lightning fast so you can just be
like i want to see 10 000 generations
of this rule play out like faster than
your eye can even follow and it's like
amazing so i highly recommend it if this
is at all intriguing to you getting
golly on your
uh ios device and you can do this kind
of process which i really enjoy doing
which is almost from like putting a
darwin hat on or a biologist head-on and
doing analysis
of a higher level of abstraction like
the organisms that spring up
because there's different kinds of
organisms like you can think of them as
species and they interact with each
other
they can uh there's gliders they shoot
diff there's like
things that can travel around there's
things that can
glider guns that can generate those
gliders
you can use the same kind of language as
you would about describing a biological
system
so it's a wonderful laboratory and it's
kind of a rebuke to someone who
doesn't think that like very very rich
complex structure can
come from very simple underlying laws
like it definitely can now
here's what's interesting if you just
picked like some random
rule you wouldn't get interesting
complexity i think that's one of the
most interesting
things of these uh one of these most
interesting features
of this whole subject that the rules
have to be tuned just right like a sort
of
typical rule set doesn't generate any
kind of interesting behavior
yeah but some do and i don't
think we have a clear way of
understanding which do and which don't
maybe stephen thinks he does i don't
know
but no no it's a giant mystery what
stephen what stephen wolfram did
is um now there's a whole interesting
aspect of the fact that he's a little
bit of an outcast in the mathematics and
physics community
because he's so focused on a particular
his particular work
i think if you put ego aside which i
think
unfairly some people are not able to
look beyond i think his work is actually
quite brilliant
but what he did is exactly this process
of darwin like exploration
is taking these very simple ideas and
writing a thousand page book on them
meaning like let's play around with this
thing let's see
and can we figure anything out spoiler
alert
no we can't in fact he does uh he does a
challenge
i think it's like a rule 30 challenge
which is quite interesting just
simply for machine learning people for
mathematics people
is can you predict the middle column for
his it's a
it's a it's a 1d cellular automata
can you pre generally speaking can you
predict
anything about how a particular rule
will evolve
just in the future uh very simple just
looking at one particular part of the
world
just zooming in on that part you know
100 steps ahead can you predict
something
and uh the the the challenge is to do
that kind of prediction
so far as nobody's come up with an
answer but the point is like
we can't we don't have tools or maybe
it's impossible or
i mean he has these kind of laws of
irreducibility they hear firstly but his
poetry it's like we can't prove these
things it seems like we can't that's the
basic
uh it almost sounds like ancient
mathematics or something like that where
you
like the gods will not allow us to
predict the cellular automata
but uh that's fascinating that we can't
i'm not sure what to make of it and
there is power to calling
this particular set of rules game of
life as conway did
because not actually exactly sure but i
think he had a sense that there's
some core ideas here that are
fundamental
to life to complex systems to the way
life emerged on earth
i'm not sure i think conway thought that
it's something that i mean conway always
had a rather ambivalent
relationship with the game of life
because i think he
saw it as it was certainly the thing he
was most famous for in the outside world
and i think that he his view which is
correct
is that he had done things that were
much deeper mathematically than that you
know
and i think it always like grieved him a
bit that he was like the game of life
guy
when you know he proved all these
wonderful theorems and like did i mean
created all these wonderful games like
created the surreal numbers like i mean
he did i mean
he was a very tireless guy who like just
like did like an incredibly variegated
array of stuff so he was exactly the
kind of person who
you would never want to like reduce to
like one achievement you know what i
mean
you